so many faces out there and so many
young faces it's nice to not be the only
young Fates around here up here at the
table which is fantastic
for those who don't know me my name is
Ben Bell I am New Zealand's youngest
mayor currently and currently the mayor
of the gore District
I'd like to extend a warm welcome to you
all to the swearing in ceremony for the
2023 Gore District youth Council
to those of you elected to the youth
Council congratulations it's great to
see the next generation of young people
Keen to make a district difference in
our district
being a young person myself I actually
fall into the bracket of being able to
be on youth Council so it's nice to see
like I said at the start so many young
faces around the table as well
listen in politics things you can some
sometimes things can sometimes feel
daunting to remember you've got a great
team around you including myself and a
number of counselors who are here today
so don't ever be afraid to ask questions
the only stupid question is the one that
you never ask
being part of the council provides you
and those around you a voice there might
otherwise be silent
it is important part of capturing a key
component in our community
so make use of that voice speak up for
the things you're passionate about work
hard and don't forget most of all to
have fun
I wish you all the very best for your
time in the youth Council be proud of
yourselves and have a fantastic year
I'd like to now without further Ado
invite each of the youth councilors up
one by one to say their declaration
so first up we have Charlotte Rudd so
I'll come over to you
declare that I will honestly honestly
and accordingly to the best of my
ability perform in the interests of the
good District
the duties given to me as a youth
counselor
thank you
next up if I could call Cynthia mwangi
to the stand
I Cynthia mwangi declare that I will
honestly and according to the best of my
ability of Performing the interests of
the Youth of the gore District the
duties given to me as a youth counselor
[Applause]
next up Matilda McLeod
I'm Tony McLeod to kill declare that I
will honestly and according to the best
of my ability perform in the interests
of Youth of the of the Youth of the gore
District the duties given to me as youth
counselor
[Applause]
Pinal mixed up
declare that I will honestly and
accordingly to the best of my ability
perform in the entrance interest of the
youth youth of the gore District the
duties given to me as a youth counselor
okay
[Applause]
Connor Swain
I Connor Swain declare that I will
honestly and according to the best of my
ability perform in the interests of the
Youth of the gore District the duties
given to me as a youth counselor
[Applause]
declare that I will honestly and
accordingly to the abuse of my ability
perform in the interests of the Youth of
the gore District the duties given to me
as a youth counselor
thank you
Sam Copland
I Sam Copeland declare that all honestly
and according to the best of my ability
perform in the interest of the Youth of
the gore District the duties given to me
as a youth counselor
[Applause]
Matthew Clinton
aye Matthew Clinton declare that I
honestly and according to the best of my
ability perform in the interests of the
Youth of the gore District the duty has
given to me as a youth counselor
[Applause]
thank you
Paige Harris
I paid chairs to clear that I will
honestly and according to the best of my
ability perform in the interest of the
youth of the Youth of the gore District
the duties given to me as a youth
counselor
[Applause]
analy Wilson
I Emily Wilson declared that I will
honestly and accordingly to the best of
my ability perform my interests of the
youth Council of the gore District given
Duty given the duties to me as a youth
counselor
thank you
Sophie Crawford
I Sophie Crawford declared that our
honestly and according to the best of my
ability performing the interests of the
Youth of the gore District the duties
given to me as a youth counselor
[Applause]
Holly Crawford
I hope I holy declare that I will
honestly and according to the best of my
ability perform in the interest of the
Youth of the gore District the duties
given to me as a youth Council
thank you
[Applause]
Amy Davidson Watts
I Amy Davis declare that I will honestly
and according to the best of my ability
performing the interests of the Youth of
the gore District the duties given to me
at the youth Council counselor
[Applause]
Aiden shiton
I Eden shouldn't care that I honesty and
according to the best of my ability
perform in the interests of the Youth of
the gore district and the duties given
to me as a youth councilor
foreign
[Applause]
well done everyone there was some uh
there were some really good signatures
in there I think some of your signatures
were better than mine
um next up we well actually let's give
everyone a big round of applause just to
congratulate everyone all together
[Applause]
next up I'd like to invite uh Deputy
Mayor Keith hoval to the stage he wants
to share a couple of words
um with the new youth Council
thank you you worship first of all thank
you to the young people for making
yourselves available for the Youth
Council it is a commitment that you're
entering into to assist not only
your like fellow youth but also the
wider community and some of the things
you do so congratulations for being here
you bring with you a range of different
skills experience and interests some of
you might have an interest in the social
side of things others may have projects
that you'd like counsel to advance some
of you might want to get involved in
some of the activities of what the
council does of what happens around the
council table it's up to you you're the
ones who are controlling your own time
and the way that you use it on the youth
Council
I do hope however that amongst you and
some of you may have an interest in
actually helping us out with some of our
policies that we're looking at over the
next year or so and one in particular
that's very topical at present is
environmental issues particularly
climate change
I'm part of a regional group that's
looking at climate change and each of
the councils is required to have a look
at it so if as a youth Council that's
something you would like to have some
input in in terms of what you think the
council policy should be what you think
may be what the council should be doing
then I'm quite happy to come along and
take you through the ABC of how you
could possibly go around it so that's
just an example one of the things that
you might be able to or might have an
interest to get involved with overview
term this coming
period of three years with the youth
Council so I wish you well in your
endeavors however you wish to use it and
once again congratulations
I'm going to invite markup just say
three few words as well
thank you may
uh first of all a huge huge thank you to
you all for coming along today and
supporting our youth Council it means a
lot to us and congratulations to all of
our new Youth councilors and those that
are returning
um I'm really really looking forward to
working with you again this year
um as you can see we have a very young
very diverse and a very very motivated
youth Council this year we're looking to
take things to the next level in terms
of working within the community and
making things happen
um giving them a chance to have more
responsibilities and to increase their
confidence as the year goes on as well
we're also looking to engage more with
elected members and to provide a youth
perspective on conversations that are
going on locally as councilor hovel has
alluded to
um I need to let you know that next week
is our first meeting we're going to get
straight into things and I need those of
you who are interested in becoming
either the chair or the vice chair
to have a think about what you could say
next week so that we have an election to
decide who will be the chair and vice
chair
so the more the better
again I'd like to say how excited I am
to work with you this year and before
you head off we'd like to ask you to
come and stand over here Ben from the
enzyme has come along today and he's
going to take a photo from the newspaper
as well and if the May and Deputy May
would like to step in as well that would
be great again thanks to all for coming
along and have a great evening
[Applause]
and that concludes our ceremony so if we
could get all the the new youth Council
up and over to this side is that right
Ben yep and we'll get a photo and then
we will um let you go and get some tea
thanks everyone